PROFESSOR: Welcome
back to recitation.
Today we're going to work on a
problem involving differential
equations.
I'm going to read it to
you, give you a little hint,
give you some time
to work on it,
and then I'll be back
and work it out for you.
So, the problem is to
find a function y equals
f of x that has the following
two properties: d squared
y dx squared is equal to 6x.
And just to remind you what
this means, this is really,
this is the second derivative
of y with respect to x.
So, the second derivative with
respect to x should be 6x.
And the second
condition's kind of long,
but it says the graph of the
function in the xy-plane passes
through the point (1, 1) with
a horizontal tangent there.
So let me give you one hint.
And that hint is that there are
some initial conditions buried
in here.
That's why we have
this condition.
So I'm going to give
you a little bit of time
to work on it and I'll be back
and I'll work it out with you.
Welcome back.
Hopefully you were
able to start at least
solving the problem
initially, give yourself
a little direction.
So let's see how you did.
OK, so the first thing
I would like to do
is try and figure out maybe
what the first derivative
of the function y
equals f of x is.
I have its second
derivative, so in order
to find the first
derivative I want
to find, ultimately, a function
that when I take its derivative
I get 6x.
Right?
So, we can think about this.
Maybe the easiest
thing for us to do
would actually be to
consider another function
whose derivative is 6x.
And we'll know that's dy dx.
So I'm going to say this: dy--
sorry-- d squared y dx squared,
I'm going to say is the first
derivative of another function,
we'll say dw/dx.
And the reason I'm
going to do that
is so we're not too
nervous about how
we solve this problem.
So let's just assume that.
So I'm introducing
another function w,
which is the first
derivative of y with respect
to x, ultimately.
Because its derivative
is the second derivative
of y with respect to x.
So let's see how to solve the
differential equation dw/dx
equals 6x.
Now you may be able
to do that right away.
You may see what
this is right away.
If you're a little
nervous, we can
do a separation of variables.
So right away, maybe
some of you can
see that this will be
2x-- sorry-- 3 x squared.
But let's just double-check.
So, separation of
variables, on this side
we get the integral of dw.
On this side we get
the integral of 6x dx.
Here we get a w.
And here, again we
get, we should really
do 6 x squared over
2 plus a constant.
So that's 3 x squared
plus a constant.
I'm going to write
c_1 here because we're
went to need a little
bit of information.
We're going to need
another constant later.
So we actually now know the
derivative of y with respect
to x.
What we found here, I'll
just write that in, is dy/dx.
Again, let me remind you why.
We had-- we were saying
the second derivative of y
with respect to x we're
going to call dw/dx.
So when I took an integral
of dw/dx, I got w.
So that means I've taken
one antiderivative here
and so now I have dy/dx.
So this is dy/dx.
I'm going to draw a line
and now we want to find y.
And again we can use
separation of variables.
Or this time I'm
just going to do
the problem without
separating variables,
because I actually know what an
antiderivative is of this, what
an antiderivative
is of this, and then
I need to add one more constant.
So I can say that y is
definitely equal to x cubed
plus c_1*x plus c_2.
And let me just again,
let's see why that is.
Right?
This antiderivative
of this is x cubed.
Antiderivative of
this is-- it's a
constant so its
antiderivative is c_1 times x.
And then I have to add
on another constant
because I have a whole
family of possible solutions.
So here I have y.
And now I need to figure
out how to use number two.
Maybe before you even go
on, you want to check,
does this really
satisfy number one?
So if we wanted to
check that, we just
take two derivatives
of this expression
on the right-hand side.
Two derivatives of this is 0.
Two derivative of this is 0.
And two derivatives
of this is 6x.
So I do indeed get what I want.
So now we definitely
can go on to number 2.
OK?
So, what do we have?
Number two, it says we have
some initial conditions here.
The graph in the xy-plane
passes through the point (1, 1)
and it has a horizontal
tangent there.
Now what does that
actually mean?
Let's think about that.
That actually means that
two says f of 1 equals 1.
Right?
y is equal to f of x.
So we can write
this also as f of x.
So two, the first part
says that f of 1 is 1.
And what does this
second condition?
Let's check this
second condition.
It says it has a
horizontal tangent there.
Horizontal tangent means that
its derivative at that x-value
is 0.
So let me write down
that in a nice form.
The derivative at that
x-value is equal to 0.
This is a little
different, maybe,
from what we've seen previously.
In the lecture you saw examples,
at least-- certainly, where
you had one initial condition.
Here we need two
initial conditions.
And you see why, is because we
actually have two constants.
Where did that come from?
It's because we started with
a second derivative instead
of just the first derivative.
So that's kind
of, that's why you
see more initial conditions than
maybe you've seen previously.
So, let's plug these in
and let's see what we get.
If f of 1 equals 1, then
let's evaluate that.
f of 1 is equal to 1 cubed
plus 1 times c_1 plus 1 times--
or just 1, or c_2 there, sorry.
There's no x there, so just c_2.
And that all has to equal 1.
And then let's look at
what the derivative is.
The derivative is
still over here.
So f prime at 1 is equal to 3
times 1 squared, so 3 times 1,
plus c_1.
And the condition says
that equals 0, equals 0.
So we can read off.
The nice thing is this is system
of equations but one of them
is very easy to solve initially,
then we can substitute.
So what does this say?
Well 3 plus c_1 equals 0.
So c_1 is equal to
minus 3, negative 3.
If I plug in negative 3 for
c_1, in this expression,
in this equation up here, I
get negative 3 plus 1 plus c_2
has to equal 1.
If I subtract the
1's from both sides
I get negative 3 plus
c_2 has to equal 0.
So c_2 has to actually equal 3.
So the final, final
answer is evaluating,
or plugging in the c1 and the
c2 in for the constants there.
The final, final answer is
x cubed minus 3x plus 3.
So we started with a
differential equation and two
sets of initial conditions.
And we came up with one
solution that satisfies that.
Now you can look
at this, you could
graph this on a
calculator or computer
and look and see if it satisfies
that it actually passes
through the point (1, 1) and
has a horizontal tangent there.
But we know, based on our
work, that that actually
should happen.
So I think that's
where I'll stop.